I think what American is here that
immigrants are being deported for drug
offenses they imagine a foreign drug
cartel leader they don't imagine people
who grew up here who are green card
holders who have us there's a family who
have children and spouses and parents
who may have made a mistake and yet are
forced to pay the price forever Melita
Castro is a native of Guatemala and a
legal permanent resident of the United
States who came to this country in the
1980s with her family seeking
opportunity I am America this is my goal
G but sometimes working paying taxes and
integrating into American culture isn't
always enough without full citizenship a
tiny mistake from your past can come
back and destroy everything you've built
which may lead to learned the hard way
immigration they come in knock at the
door he didn't explain nothing to me he
say he showed me a mug shot and you say
I got a warning for your office one
fateful night more than 20 years ago
lolita was pulled over in a routine
traffic stop unaware that two of her
passengers were in possession of a small
amount of cocaine but everyone in the
car was arrested because of the threat
of deportation a lawyer advised her to
take a plea for simple possession a
misdemeanor I was appointed to a lawyer
and the lawyer told me you don't have no
trouble you just gotta play guilty pay a
fine I'll do some community hours and
you're gonna be fine though she is a
green card holder who had passed her
citizenship test maletas questionable
scrape with the law took her away from
her three children and a mother's
suffering from Alzheimer's and forced
her into one of the most draconian and
inhumane pockets of the American legal
system a detention center almost two
hours from her home where she was
forbidden from even touching her
children during visits my little
daughter was watching me in the gargoyle
I have so bad and then after dark they
brought you to our room knowing that you
don't touch your family they make you
take all your clothes off and then they
make you in a position like a squat and
you gotta cough how does someone with
one minor blemish on their record who's
dead is supposedly paid end up locked up
with no legal recourse grace Meng of
Human Rights Watch published a report
detailing dozens of cases like this
explains the increase in deportations is
largely because the Obama administration
has really focused on deporting anyone
with their criminal conviction and in
this country drug arrests are quite
common from 2070 2012
over a quarter of a million non-citizens
were deported who's most serious
conviction was a drug offense and among
that number we know that the most common
type of conduct was possession once
deported that man is permanent you can
never return to live with your family in
the US again while maleta was detained
her mother suffering from Alzheimer's
was left without her primary caretaker
Melita was also unable to help her
pregnant daughter as her due date
approached it was so devastating not
having her though like i mislike her
going into the hallway and calling my
name like i woke up every morning trying
to anticipating that and it wasn't there
so the house just felt so empty our
biggest fear was like losing our mom
obviously but then also like how do we
react to losing our mom what were our
options do we go all the way back to
Guatemala Guatemala's beautiful but it's
just scary place to be or do we stay
here and kind of love our mom from a
distance which is terrible because she
should be here after seven months in
detention and after accruing extensive
legal bills a judge ruled that maleta
had never been a drug trafficker and set
her free but because of a broadly
written law and it's blunt enforcement
she missed many of the final days of her
mother's life the birth of her grandson
and to hear her tell it she missed a lot
more than that my teeth you know hoping
he's saying be sure that they they walk
that right went to school there
nothing's gonna happen my plans my music
my family my food they laundry the smell
of the laundry they say you you don't
think that you're gonna miss ya it was
hard real hard what can be done to
alleviate the needless suffering of
law-abiding residents of the United
States who may or may not have ever
committed a crime there is so little
political appetite do anything that
helps immigrants that laws that many
people recognize are unfair that are
leading to families being separated torn
apart they're continuing to stay on the
books and they're being enforced to the
hilt though she is already passed at
once Melita is scheduled to take her
citizenship test again and if all goes
as she hopes at long last she will be an
American citizen next year this is
wearing really belong this is my house
my family my kids are here all that they
not born here my grandkids so this is
home for me